so there's an eight-year-old girl she
was playing out around her backyard she
was hunting for mushrooms when an older
teenage male 17 year old guy comes out
of the woods and tries to kidnap her he
said when the guy was apprehended later
he said he wanted to beat the girl so
this 13 year old boy sees this happening
pulls out his slingshot and just dings
this guy right in the head at that
moment the girl had the opportunity to
run away and then the 13 year old got
him again and so the the 17 year old ran
off but the fact that he was pinged in
the head with the rocks made it easier
to apprehend him and so he's now been
arrested I bet everybody who hears that
story is going to say this is a really
great happy story thank goodness that
little boy had a slingshot he's like a
regular old Bart Simpson then some
people would fail to follow the logic of
that story to our second amendment
rights